so i'm gonna say right here that i genie
my
going into my marriage i want to submit
to my man
let me explain okay before you start
feeling some type of way
genie mai is just letting people know
she doesn't want to be the leader
when it comes to her marriage with her
fiance jeezy
girls it's tiring being the boss of me
it's tiring leading all the time
all the time
the real co-host is tired of making so
many decisions when it comes to her
career
she likes the idea of her man taking the
lead at home
i'm a very dominant woman i own my
business
i lead my teams i played my own manager
my own publicist my own lawyer
when i didn't have money to have those
people so i make the decisions in my
life when i come home
i am i i like
the idea that my man leads us
and she's making one thing clear being
submissive
doesn't mean she's lower than her
husband that doesn't mean
that in this case jay makes all the
decisions for us that doesn't mean that
when he says
how are we spending our money or where
are we moving that i just say yes sir
or yes you're your honor like it's not
that it's a you know what i think that
we would do best here i want to do this
and he takes the decision he formulates
it with our overall vision and he
leads us and i like to submit to that
jeannie said
how she grew up definitely played a
factor in deciding what type of marriage
she wants to have
my mom has a very she has a very strong
force and she took over a lot of
decisions in the household
to the point that my dad unless it was
always going to be a fight he was like
you know what
go ahead whatever you want to decide go
ahead and i'm just going to do me and
that causes a wedge
and i can have that tendency i'm just
saying for me i can have that tendency
to follow like my mom because it's what
i grew up in and i saw it
but we have a feeling this whole
submissive thing is working for jeannie
and jeezy
i mean hello the man bought her a
billboard proving he knows how to lead
i just want to wish you luck on your big
night tonight
for you
jeannie is currently competing on this
season of dancing with the stars
but jeezy took matters into his own
hands by telling fans to vote for her
who gets their fiance a billboard
just to encourage people to vote for
dancing with the stars
but on their birthday it's his birthday
right now
and he's busy getting me a billboard to
help me garner votes
it's incredible
you